it will have to be
poorer and ordinary families that have
to reduce their energy consumption so i
honestly don't think this plan
is going to successfully
save ordinary families
from being in cold homes this winter
because the energy is not there the rich
are not going to reduce their
consumption which means ordinary
families will still have to reduce their
consumption i think what this shows us
is that our government is taking a
phenomenally naive approach to an energy
crisis
which is we have less energy
but the government rather than trying to
manage a reduction in usage of energy is
just giving out money but money is not
energy
if there's less energy
you need to manage it so that the people
have the most excessive energy
consumption reduce their energy usage
that is the only way to save ordinary
families and we're doing nothing to do
that nothing to do that which means rich
people will not reduce the energy
consumption which means ultimately
families will still go cold